هذا المشهد القاتم حذرت اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر من ان تؤدي اثار الزلزال
الاخير الى تفاقم اوضاع الاسر السوريه
وقالت ان الحاجه الى المساعدات الطارئه في
سوريا بلغت اعلى مستوياتها على الاطلاق
بعد 12 عاما من الحرب المدمره وتدمير نصف
المرافق الصحيه واضافت اللجنه ان العائلات
السوريه تحتاج الى الامدادات الاساسيه من
غذاء وماوى وادويه وان تمويل العمل
الانساني في سوريا منخفض للغايه
تنضم الينا من بيروت ايمان طرابلسي
المتحدثه الاقليبيه للجنه الدوريه للصليب
الاحمر سيده ايمان تتحدثون عن ان التمويل
ضعيف جدا في سوريا هل ترى عليه اي دعم او
تغيير بعد كارثه الزلزال
مرحبا بالفعل وللاسف عمليات العمليات
الانسانيه في سوريا شهدت على امتداد
السنوات الاخيره تراجع حتى اننا اصبحنا
نشير الى الازمه الانسانيه التي
تحتقن وتتازم مع مرور كل يوم في سوريا على
امتداد كل سنوات الاخيره على انها من بين
الازمات الانسانيه المنسيه في العالم
اليوم هناك ضروره قصوى بان تتواصل حمله
الدعم والتضامن التي نشهدها اليوم من من
حول العالم
التضامنا مع ماسي السكان في سوريا وخاصه
المناطق المنكوبه في شمال سوريا اليوم بان
يكون هذا التضامن غير مقترن فقط بالاحداث
وان يتواصل على مستوى البعيد والمتوسط لان
الناس وفور مرور المرحله الاستعجاليه التي
نشهدها اليوم في هذه المناطق المنكوبه سوف
يكون علينا على على بقيه الفاعلين
الانسانيين بما فيهم الصليب الاحمر الدولي
ب كذلك للاحتياجات الطويله المدى ومتوسطه
على سبيل المثال اعاده تاهيل او محاوله
محاوله اعاده تاهيل البنيه البنيه
الاساسيه التحتيه التي
يحتاجها السكان اليوم بشكل بشكل بشكل حاد
كنا بالفعل نتحدث عن ازمه انسانيه حاده
حتى قبل وقوع هذا الزلزال ولكننا اليوم
نتحدث عن ازمه اضافيه تحدث على خلفيه هذه
هذا الوضع الكارثي لديك الذي كان قائم
بالفعل خاصه على امتداد السنوات الاخيره
وبالتالي اليوم الاحتياجات الاسد ما هي
الاولويات على المدى القصير وعلى المدى
الطويل وكيف تقيمون الاستجابه الدوليه بعد
تسعه ايام من الزلزال
للاسف اليوم نحن ما نراه ميدانيا هو ان
هناك حاجه ماسه لكل المساعدات الانيه
والمنقذه للحياه بما فيها الغذاء بما فيها
تاهيل الملاجئ والمئاوي الاحتياجات الصحه
الاساسيه كذلك
ومساعده
المؤسسات الصحيه الموجوده في المدن التي
تضررت بشكل كبير ولكن كذلك يجب النظر الى
ما فتره ما بعد الكارثه اليوم للاسف
المساعدات التي يتحصل عليها السكان في كل
المناطق المنكوبه هي تعد نقطه في بحر ما
يحتاجونه فعليا نحن نتحدث عن سكان كانوا
بالفعل يعانون من حاله هشاشه كبيره سواء
كان ذلك على المستوى الاجتماعي وعلى
المستوى الاقتصادي
وهذا يحد من قدرتهم اليوم على التعامل مع
هذه الاحتياجات الاضافيه التي خلفها هذا
الزلزال المدمر الناس اليوم يحتاج الى
غذاء يحتاجون الى ماوى ملائم لوضعيه الطقس
التي التي تشهد تراجع كبير في درجات
الحراره حاليا
والناس يعيشون في ملاجئ ليست بالضروره
مهيئه لهذه لهذه الاجواء
الطقس الحالي وكذلك نتحدث عن ضروره قصوى
لتاهيل مؤسسات الصحيه بالمستلزمات الطبيه
المنقذه للحياه الصليب الاحمر الدولي
بالشراكه مع الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري
تمكنا خلال الاسبوع الفارط من تقديم
مساعدات فيما يخص
المساعدات الغذائيه الماء الصالح للشراب
بالنسبه للمئوي خاصه في في اللاذقيه حلب
وحمى وكذلك ساعدنا وزاره الصحه بتاهيل او
مسانده المؤسسات الصحيه
بالمعدات اللازمه
لاسعاف الجرح الخيرين وتقديم اكياس ولكن
اليوم يبقى هذا جزء صغير مما يجب ان يقدم
وبالتالي كل الخطى التي من الممكن ان تتخذ
من طرف جميع الاطراف المنخرطه في النزاع
السوري اليوم التي من شانها ان تسرع في
وصول
الاغاثه اللازمه لكل المناطق المنكوبه هي
مرحب بها طيب هل جاءت الاستجابه الدوليه
على قدر الحدث على مستوى الحدث في سوريا
سيده ايمان
نحن نتحدث عن عن سياق يعاني من من من نزاع
قائم الى اليوم يعني قرابه 12 سنه منذ
اندلاع النزاع في سوريا وبالتالي الوضع هو
جد معقد يعني من غير الممكن ان نربط عدم
وصول الاغاثه اللازمه بالشكل الذي نريده
الى الى الى الى الى طرف معين او الى سبب
واحد لان الظروف التي تتشابك لكي تجعل من
عمليات الاغاثه معقده هي عديده ولكن اليوم
نداءنا هو واضح يجب ان تصل الاغاثه
اللازمه والمنقذه للحياه لكل المناطق
المنكوبه لاننا اليوم نتحدث عن مساله حياه
او موت بالنسبه للعشرات الالاف من
العائلات الذين يفتقدون اليوم الى الغذاء
الى الدواء الى الماوى وان وننادي من ترى
يعني ننادي كل الاطراف المنخرطه في النزاع
بان تضع
التجاذبات او الاحترازات السياسيه على
جانب وان يتم فقط التركيز على
الاحتياجات الانسانيه الملحه والمنقذه
للحياه اليوم
السيده ايمان طرابلسي المتحدثه الاقليميه
للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر كنت معنا من
بيروت